[Música]
dicen que soy creativa
yo nunca hice las cosas para que me
invitaran
sino por el placer de hacerlas
soy un autodidacta total nadie me enseñó
nada siempre hice las cosas por
intuición y por ganas
cuando una maestra de tercer grado de la
escuela rawson
con mis
jóvenes 19 años 18 años
puse en escena el teatro lo hecho en
nuestro querido teatro gualeguaychú
caperucita y el lobo
con lo que está en vivo
o sea que ya
entonces el audaz y atrevida
durante los 18 años que tuve mi
zapatería y marroquinería
decían que vidrieras eran hermosas
pero yo las hacía por placer que sentía
en hacer vidrieras con elementos
inventados por mí
siempre fue muy inquieta
siempre usaba mis manos
hasta el día de hoy
sigo creando también me dediqué a hacer
carrozas estudiantiles
para eso mi marido que era un divino me
hizo un garage inmenso en la que podía
poner dos carrozas a la vez en 1979
fuimos
un grupo de tres matrimonios amigos
y el doctor barret y si quiere
presidente de central entrerriano haber
unas comparsas que venían de paso de los
libres al volvernos le dije
al doctor ballet y cuando quieras te
hago una
yo no sabía que esta frase iba a cambiar
la historia de tantas personas
pero por sobre todo mi historia
en 1979 los clubes tenían que presentar
algo artístico para poder integrar
a los clubes que iban a ser los dueños
del carnaval
porque hasta entonces era gratuito
por eso apareció el gringo gareth is a
pedirme que cumpliera con mi promesa
pero quería que la cumpliera un mes se
imaginarán que en un mes no puedo ser
una comparsa
así que decidieron
hacer una carroza entonces la carroza
vino a casa derechito a casa en casa lo
hicimos competimos y ganamos
y de allí en más
el club central entrerriano fue parte de
la comisión de carnaval
en 1980
ya pensando en la carroza que les había
prometido
mandé a mi marido ya mis hijos al campo
unos días para quedarme sola y poder
diseñar los trajes de la comparsa que
iba a competir en enero de 1981
termina los terminados los diseños los
despliegue en el suelo como formando una
comparsa
en realidad no era lo que yo quería que
hubiera querido algo más importante pero
el club no contaba con recursos
suficientes para más gastos
tenía que pensar qué nombre ponerle a
esta comparsa que con tanta audacia
encare
viajando buenos aires con mis hijos y mi
marido
y va repitiendo en voz alta distintas
opciones hasta que me cansa van y las
desecha va
y de pronto me acordé de un hombre que
había leído en un libro de una palabra
que quería decir buen día en idioma
mapuche
y esa palabra esas palabras eran marín
marín
no me imaginé que iba a calar tan hondo
en la historia de gualeguaychú este
nombre
es el de la comparsa más famosa del país
y la más ganadora en la historia de
gualeguaychú
como les conté antes el club no contaba
con medio suficiente como para hacer
algo de gran envergadura por ello tuve
que resignar ciertas cosas por ejemplo
las plumas que a mí me encantaría me
viene encantado ponerlas
pero se me ocurrió ir al campo de mi
marido con un grupo de chicos de marí
marí
de antemano le había pedido del capataz
que me que me encerraron 300 gansos en
el huevo de la manga
y nos pusimos a desplomar gansos fue
toda una odisea y muy gracioso y muy
divertido con esas plumas hicimos boas
que tenemos de distintos colores de
acuerdo a los trajes
y las dañando es me la mandó después el
capataz porque cuando nosotros quisimos
ir a donde estaban ellos se fueron
corrieron otros campos así que fue
imposible bueno esta etapa estaba
resuelta
ahora hablemos de la batucada
fuimos a porto allegre
compramos instrumentos de percusión
porque a nosotros con mi marido
queríamos samba brasilero que nos
enloquecía éramos unos enamorados de ese
ritmo así que queríamos percusión por
ello fuimos a porto alegre y compramos
bastante pero pero el de batucada no
sonaba como queríamos así que fueron a
paso de los libres mi marido
jorge valeri que el director de la
batucada y jorge reynoso que la parte de
él
del grupo musical a ver qué pasaba
y la que faltaban distintos tipos de
instrumentos
cuando completamos la instrumentación
salió perfecta
en cuanto a la música nos quedamos con
mi marido toda una noche escuchando
discos de samba
y bueno al amanecer casi
escuchamos uno el canta canta de martino
de ávila
nos encantó así que ese fue te diría que
hoy es el himno de mari marín
la siguiente tarea
fue comprar el material para hacerla
fuimos a buenos aires a la base y redon
donde una gran tienda que provee a los
teatros
de buenos aires
porque por pura coincidencia nos
encontramos con el doctor martínez
garbino que compraba para papelitos y
con marc gené nada cal que compraba para
darle vida
y ellos compraban ricas telas
y yo cuando me toca el turno pido dos
piezas de lienzo
y eso fue todo lo que compre
pero a tres cuadras de ahí por calle
lavalle me voy al palé de visu y compro
piedras checoslovacas padre vallet
mostacillas canutillos perlas con las
que cubrimos la actual actual esquís y
que hice para cada traje
sin que seguida un milímetro de lienzo
trabajo para ganar no me permito
un fracaso
pero nunca pensé
que el canta canta
que la percusión y que las hermosas
chicas iban a lo que sea tanto al
público de gualeguaychú
en mil 982 nos fuimos a san pablo
compramos las plumas tan codiciadas por
mí incorpore las variadas
que también son mujeres muy queridas que
le doy mucha importancia a ellas porque
son parte
parte necesaria e indispensables en el
carnaval de río yo tengo tres modistas
en el taller la principal de ella me
dice negrita madre de dos de tres vayan
as no se pueden hacer porque no hay
tiempo
yo me planto y le digo litera
yo diseñé 19 mañanas y 19 vayan as van a
salir
ha sido en 1983
no la pude hacer porque mis hijos me
pidieron encarecidamente que me dedicara
a ellos porque no tenían ni madre ni
casa
así que así que con mi marido decidimos
ir a conocer el carnaval de río
fuego maravilloso
en el 84 vino a casa un directivo de
central a pedirme que por favor les
diera una mano
porque las dos directoras que no eran de
gualeguaychú tenían problemas
y yo le dije que yo no podía porque mis
hijos me mataba
les había prometido que no
pero les recomendé que fueran a cámara
porque yo en el 83 había vislumbrado una
comparsa de cámara que me gustó mucho un
genio y me parecía que ese genio era muy
joven por ciertas cosas que vi así que
fueran lo contrataran y no lo dejaron
escapar
así fue 'josé luis' gestro
desde el 84 que la hizo gana nuevamente
no se movió nunca más de mar y mar y
hasta que partió a los 33 años
marí marí fue tocada por la varita
mágica
dijo service
gestro y sin adrián butter
marí marí no sería lo que soy
40 años después le diría a los jóvenes
que tienen inclinaciones artísticas o
que no saben que las tienen
que indaguen en ellos mismos porque van
a descubrir algo pueden descubrirse
realmente como seres creativos
compruébenlo pónganlas en prácticas usen
sus manos y se pueden dar una bella
sorpresa